[موسيقى]
بردك تعبانه يعني الناس تقول لك حتى ناخد
الحاجات الاكل اللي هي بسيطه نيجي تكلفه
عاليه جدا جدا يعني وفي ناس طبعا مش قادره
اصلا تشتري حاجه
[موسيقى]
ما لناش دعوه ما حدش يجيب سيره الحب
احنا هنا احنا هنا ايه احنا هنا ايه
الحاجه متوفره والحمد لله بس سعرها غالي
ليه احنا عايزين نعرف الغبي ده غبي بس مش
عايزين نعرف اكتر من كده وحدوا الاسعار
قولوا السعر ده بكذا والكل يعمل بالسعر ده
يبقى عارفين نازلين عارفين هنشتري ايه لكن
دلوقتي كل واحد بيبيع بسعر معنى كده مفيش
رقابه على المسؤول
[موسيقى]
طبعا في الاسعار كانت الاول كانت رخيصه
غير كده خالص الاسعار زادت يمكن ضعفين او
ثلاث اضعاف ومن ناحيه
السحب اللي بياخد اللي كان بياخد خمس
فردات دلوقتي بياخذ فرختين اللي كان بياخد
فرختين بيجي ياخد ياخد مثلا ايه فرخه وورك
لذلك التقطيع هو اللي بيبقى ماشي اليومين
دول
[موسيقى]
الرز مثلا كان 12 جنيه دلوقتي
اه كل واحد بيبيع بمزاجه
واحنا بنجيب على قد مقدارتنا دلوقتي لكن
بيجيب 3 كيلو الرز بيجيب كيلو
يعني احنا مالنا طب ما في حاجات احنا فين
مواردنا احنا وفين شغلنا احنا
[موسيقى]